are you guys done well we're good we
want to know more importantly how you
are here tonight talking about
relationships reality TV what's this
discussion gonna be like we're talking
about tonight I don't know I just flew
out for the vacation I guess it's all
news to me I just heard what we're
talking about tonight but whatever guess
I'm kind of used to what whatever
there's no question that I haven't
answered already yeah you've been
through it all
apparently well you're with your lady
here tonight right how's that
relationship going great that's the
first time she's ever been to I guess
our industry so yeah it's been four
years what makes you so happy being with
her um she makes everything normal and
comfortable and we have normal lives and
this isn't really normal for us no it's
just it's good you know to travel and
get to see different things and it's
like reliving my past but with someone
that I really love and care about your
dad reliving your past like family life
and all those normal we're living my
past just in a geographical area well I
mean you've had ups and downs one thing
we love seeing is that Colin is back in
your life in a very real way
what exactly happened with that and how
did that end up happening how do you
feel about it I can't really go into
detail about not at this time about what
happened but just know that he is coming
home to our house and he's gonna enjoy
the holiday with us and go to school and
be with his sister Hannah and he's
really excited we're really excited to
have him home for the holidays and to
enjoy the rest of his childhood and our
care does that mean he will be with you
for the foreseeable future indefinitely
yes
indefinitely and I say us like me Hannah
Colleen and her children what does that
feel for you it has to feel good you
fought to see your kids for a long time
I've been fighting for 10 years so I'll
keep fighting as long as I have to or
will or whatever they want to do as well
and I always said that from the
beginning and it's always a very dynamic
situation so who is Colin I mean I grew
up watching your family and people just
loved you and your kids how is he doing
he's doing really well he actually just
called us 10 minutes before our car
arrived and I was like I'm really sorry
and trying to explain like California
three-hour time difference and because
he's in Pennsylvania and we gotta go I
love you and he's like oh man and then
we had to come here but he's doing
really well and he'll have some
adjustment issues just socialization
wise but he's like so intuitive and so
lovey-dovey and all that kind of stuff
but you know his sister's really excited
and he's really excited to start school
and back in the neighborhood and all
that kind of thing it's normalized well
I mean like you said fighting for your
kids for 10 years where are things that
with you and Kate right now in terms of
communication and we don't communicate
we don't even text anymore so I mean the
last time we communicated with her it
was probably either their attorneys or
in court and I say that like minimal but
I mean that's the way it's been and I
guess that's what works I mean it's a
it's a shame that we can't co-parent and
I know the whole world wants us to and
lawyers and therapists and on judges and
all these people want it just doesn't
work so you you know the other kids as
they get older I me and Karen Maddie
just turned 18 right so do you think
your relationships with them will change
get better what do you think I hope my
relationship with Mady and Cara will get
better but they're adults now so that
kind of just hinges on them and I kind
of you know being estranged from them
I've kind of learned to live with it now
but it's really up to them so you decide
what they want to do with that
I kind of left it in the court now
because it's been so long I mean it is
kind of heartbreaking and I do miss them
but everyone grows and matures and
understands things you know I tried
really hard to develop something with
them and what only time will tell I
guess having been through what you've
been through anything you go back and
feel like I learned this so you'd give
people who are going through what you've
gone through advice and say you know
take this piece of advice for me there's
certain things I've learned along the
way I mean I I know I've made some
mistakes I guess I regret certain things
I mean but it's all with maturity you
know lessons learned and no matter what
you do but I think the way things played
out is wait that's how you learn live
and learn I mean I'm not the brightest
some films shed sometimes but you know
I'm 41 you know and I'm gonna learn
lessons along the way but uh I love my
kids they know I love them just some
things don't work out the way they do
but being in the public eye too doesn't
necessarily help things either but
things are now calming down and they'll
play out the way they get played out
just keep putting that message out there
that you love them yeah of course I mean
like even now publicly or privately I
don't really get to say things publicly
other than my Instagram but even then
what you wanna I love you Mady Cara and
I love the rest of my kids I mean I get
to see Hannah and Collin but uh
and other kids now I love them too so
thank you so much for saying that it's
just such a good message and you know I
love seeing here with Colleen and happy
marriage more kids in your future what
do you think that's a lot of pressure I
don't know
that's a cliffhanger may be another red
carpet who knows
[Music]
[Applause]